some people say 2022 is a dry year for
games meanwhile game pass just keeps on
giving way to new games to play who
cares if you have an ever growing
backlog there's nothing wrong with
taking time to taste and try a new game
you wouldn't have before and game pass
is great for that so here's eight games
for you to check out microsoft's game
pass if you subscribe to it
shoot the nazis in the testicle
simulator i mean um uh sniper elite five
yeah yeah that one the highly acclaimed
sniper focus shooter franchise is back
and its latest entry is a day oneer for
game pass where most shooters tend to be
frenetic and over the top sniper elite
is a slower paced and more methodical
approach especially for military
shooters sniper elite 5 gives players
massive open-ended maps to stealth
around and experiment in their nazi
killing but of course not without some
spectacle of looking at eternal damage
you can afflict on them
[Music]
sniper elite 5 also introduces
multiplayer invasion akin to death loop
or dark souls system you can enter
another player's world as an axis sniper
and foil their nazi testicle shooting
plans but for some killing nazis is
better done with friends and thankfully
sniper elite 5 offers co-op for its
campaign missions so load up sit back
and shoot a nazi from 300 yards away
[Music]
now this is what i'm talking about
pac-man museum plus just dropped fresh
on game pass which includes 14 pac-man
chop and classics including pac-man a
game i have fond memories of of playing
on the turbo graphics which also
includes the song that for whatever
reason induces me in a state of panic
in pac-man pac-man has a bi-cock-it hat
for for some reason or
is that a fedora with a feather
and there's a fairy
and fire hydrants have gone completely
awry and i have no idea why please tell
me in the comments
if you know
anyway but there's loads of other games
like the og pac-man super pac-man pack
and pale back attack pack and time pack
goes to jail i made that one up look all
i'm trying to say is that there is a lot
packed in
it's all packaged together at a cool
interactive arcade you can customize
yourself which is really sweet and can
be decorated with collectibles unlocked
by playing the games
life finds a way and if there's anything
telling of that then it's the several
sequels in the film franchise the six
books and now jurassic world evolution 2
the management sim game where you get to
manage and create your very own jurassic
park these games are all about trying to
control and contain wild dinosaurs that
have rampaged their way across the
united states which is certainly a more
pragmatic and humane approach than
attempting to bring on their second
extinction basically you're picking up
the mess after a bunch of scientists
decided to play god and clearly the
humane thing to do is just make a park
for people to come and gawk at them
[Music]
and really that sounds like a blast
build your dream dinosaur park get
creative manage your staff explore
different environments with their own
distinct challenges there's also a
campaign with jeff goldblum himself
reprising the role of dr ian malcolm
[Music]
trek to yumi through and through is an
uncanny take on feudal japan samurai
cinema black and white check film grain
check hyper stylized presentation with
lots of wind and silence check it's hard
to imagine the samurai genre done any
other way thanks to the legendary
filmmaker akira kurosawa's influence on
the genre 60 some years ago trek to yomi
has a very classic samurai story of a
young man swearing to protect his town
and people at all costs avow to his
dying master as alone samurai you'll be
slashing parrying dodging and running
through a visually striking cinematic
landscape filled with deadly foes who
abrupt in vibrant sprays of blood all in
the name of revenge
[Music]
most games put you on the front lines of
peril fending your city off from an
alien invasion firing off with military
defenses an umaringi generation you're
shooting all right not with a gun but a
camera
as a civilian you explore the world
taking pictures and documenting the
stark reality of a world being invaded
by an alien species while the united
nations deploy military forces to defend
the planet
but you don't actually really see any of
the action happening well sort of
it's a really cool twist positioning the
player to instead see the impact of the
action rather than being directly
involved in it and despite that dour
twist umarangi generation has a
remarkably hip cyberpunk aesthetic with
a chill step electronic vaporwave vibe
while the battles commence in the
distance and you hear the constant
gunfire life for most citizens goes on
going to work consuming and existing and
that's the world you get to explore and
capture
[Music]
wake up sleeper
dreaming again set in a ruined space
station thousands of people grip onto
life surviving on the edge of an
interstellar capitalist society in this
very bleak view of a capitalistic future
you play as a sleeper a digitized human
consciousness in an artificial body that
you don't own but a corporation does
inspired by tabletop rpgs the game uses
dice and ticking clocks to move the
character forward in a world that is
responsive to your actions what paths
you take who you meet and how you
interact with them determine the story
you carve out for yourself in this
dystopian science fiction while you try
to escape the capitalistic past and
carve out your own future
alright these last few on the list are
exclusive to pc so sorry console only
folks but these next few are too good
not to include vampire survivors emerged
from obscurity to being one of the most
talked about games of 2022 and to think
it's still in early access but don't let
that misguide you even in a technically
unfinished state vampire survivors is an
incredibly addictive game that'll have
its teeth sunk into you in no time it's
a single stick shooter where all you do
is control the movement of your
character while it shoots and fires off
your weapons for you but do not be
fooled though the attacking is done for
you it's not long until you can be
swarmed with hundreds of enemies all at
once it then becomes a dance of
maneuvering through an ever-growing
horde of enemies while strategically
stacking up power-ups to fend them off
its approach ability lends itself to
quick but challenging sessions that'll
have you entranced by its vampiric gaze
and before you know it ours would have
gone by
norco is a point-and-click adventure
mystery slice of life game that begins
with the story of your missing brother
but what ensues is a series of secrets
that spans generations using a cinematic
painterly-like approach to pixel art set
in a quitting sci-fi south louisiana
you'll be exploring and unraveling a
world tarnished by oil refineries and
industrialization
accompanying its distinct art style is
an industrial soundtrack and a wide cast
of characters each with their own
backstories and motives that'll make the
solemn world feel alive and wholly
realized
and there you have it we make these
lists monthly so if there wasn't a game
you saw that you'd suggest drop it in
the comments subscription services like
game pass are a great way to try
something new that you may have not
otherwise so this month i challenge you
to boot up something you maybe wouldn't
have in the first place just to give it
a go because who knows your next
favorite game could be one you never
even considered playing in the first
place like paradise killer and yes i'm
talking specifically about me in the
meantime keep an eye out for everything
game related here at gamespot
[Applause]
[Music]